hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that just ended from
round four of the charity cup
preliminaries it's dingliran vs magnus
carlsen and nowadays when dingleroon is
announced to play in a tournament you
don't know if he will actually play in a
tournament but as this is online uh he
is now here and we are very glad to have
him so he has the white pieces and you
guys will enjoy this one a lot as it
features um a really cool opening really
cool uh development in the opening and
then uh well a very unpleasant end game
for one of the players so the ding opens
with d4 uh we have knight to f6 by
magnus c for uh g6 and now f3 going for
the sort of um uh antigua groomful
variation uh we have e6 and now e4
grabbing the full center here we have c5
magnus strikes against the center and
now d5 grabbing the center we have d6 by
magnus knight to c3 and e captures on d5
so this is all very standard stuff c
captures on d5 bishop to g7 and bishop
to g5 developing while pinning the
knight with h6 challenging the bishop
and bishop back to be back to e3 uh a6
preparing to uh
keep advancing with b5 so of course
things uh ding prevents this by playing
a4 we have casts by magnus and now queen
to d2 sort of going after the h6 pawn uh
but not really magnus just develops rook
to e8 and now what happens if you
capture the h6 pawn well that's the
that's the key idea not only uh behind
the opening choice but also uh behind
the entire game as you'll see later on
so here if you capture the the
pawn you really uh just solve all of
black's problems and you can no longer
claim that you have any
advantage you know because you had the
white pieces black just plays knight
captures on e4 attacks the queen here
and not only that he opens up this
diagonal uh you've played f3 so you have
to be very careful about any uh forks
and skewers so knight captures an e4
queen to h4 with check now we're gonna
grab the bishop g3 queen captures here
and that's it white can no longer claim
any advantage if the queens get traded
off material is equal black is the one
with the bishop's pair so if anyone's
claiming any advantage here it is most
uh most definitely black and of course
you cannot capture the knight is uh is
pinned for the moment so after rook to
e8 magnus just ding continues developing
with bishop to c4 and now knight beat
the d7 uh and here at night the h3 is an
a knight stage three is a known move
which is something that i think uh maybe
magnus in his mind thought the ding
played but instead dink played bishop
back to e2 and this amongst other things
well in
case the knight is placed on e5 the
bishop on c4 will not come under attack
but also it puts an extra piece in
between the rook and the king which will
be very important in this game as you'll
see and also it is now as of move 13
that we have a completely new game and
here magnus should just continue
developing either with queen to e7 or
rook to b8 or something like that but
after knight to e5 it becomes very very
interesting because now ding goes after
the pawn on h6 he just plays bishop
captures on h6 and now
it's not the same line as it was um
before
when you could play something like
knight captures on e4 because now
there's a knight on e5 and also a bishop
on e2 so there are two extra pieces in
between the this rook and the king and
you have to play bishop characters on h6
or just continue development saying okay
i gave up a pawn but magnus forces this
line knight captures on e4 and this
simply doesn't work knight captures on
e4 biting queen to h for check like in
the line that we've seen g3 queen
captures on h6 queen captures on h6
bishop captures an h6 and now look at
this there's a knight in the bishop here
and you can simply play knight to f6
check this is what magnus missed
unfortunately for him so okay king to f8
ding grabs the exchange we have king
capture 78 and now h4 so now uh if we
look at the position it's uh same amount
of pawns only ding is up the exchange he
has two rooks but okay magnus has the
bishop pair it's not all that's terrible
we have bishop to d7 and now h5 ding
wants to open up the h file uh put
pressure on the bishop so maybe bringing
the bishop back on the previous move was
a bit more precise than bishop to d7 but
this is rapid chess so here we have g5
knights to h3 and now g4 and here uh
there's a very tricky move for for ding
to find and that is f4 he did not play
it but we will show it because it's
super interesting g captures we're going
to play pawn captures here and now after
d captures an e5 you play g4 this allows
you to capture the
pawn on h3 and now you simply claim that
your advantage of having uh a rook over
a bishop is too great for example rule
b8 you want to play b5 we just play a5
and the white is just winning here so
okay that was in the position but
bingo's f captures on g4 and this allows
the magnus to slowly start coming back
into the game knight captures on g4 we
have bishop captures bishop captures and
now knight to f4 uh the knight is
excellently placed here and of course
any trade is favorable for ding as uh
well if magnus gives up the bishop fair
then he pretty much loses all of his
counter play so king to d7 we have king
to f2 uh getting the king away from the
only open file on the board and now
bishop to g7 attacking the b2 pawn but
it's not really under any uh pressure
because if you capture just rook b1
bishop has to move we're going to pick
up b7 and so on so here we have king to
g2 by ding and bishop to f5 by magnus
now guarding the b1 square and getting
ready to capture the pawn here and the
situation is seven minutes for ding
eight minutes for magnus so plenty of
time for both players with being having
um really an incredible position and
didn't just place king to f3 he says i
don't care about the b2 pawn i want to
have an active king and i can definitely
answer your
bishop captures on b2 idea and there's
really nothing better for magnus so he
has to go for it he plays bishop
captures on b2 but now of course you
guys know what being played uh feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for white
well i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on supporting that
you have to give a little something back
in order to win this game and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course rook a to b1 so we
attacked the bishop and now if the
bishop moves we're going to capture on
b7 and then black's entire queen side
falls apart so as we have to allow this
we better grab at least a rook before we
allow it so bishop captures them b1 rook
captures on b1 and now bishop back to e5
now we have to give up the pawn on b7
rook captures on b7 and now king the e8
you have to defend the f7 pawn
but it's very unpleasant pleasant with
your king here and the inactive rook on
a8 and also the bishop on e5 not doing
all that much uh dink can now uh win
this uh in you know in many many ways uh
nice the d3 is only one of them but the
ding says i don't care about the knight
you can trade your bishop for night i'm
just gonna play g4 now i'm gonna play g5
and then start pushing my pawns so
magnus plays rook to c8 this is the
absolute best counter play he has he
uses the c file and he wants to push his
c pawn uh hopefully to victory or or
maybe to a draw
and now dink pushes g5 it's also very
interesting but as it's a rapid game i
will show why h6 is much much stronger
point is that after c4 you don't really
have to be worried about the past c pawn
because you can just play rook b6 and
after c3 there's knight d3 uh we just
include this move very nicely and after
c2 there is a rook to c6 so you put a
rook
in between black's rook and the past
pawn and after you trade here captures
captures now the two pass pawns the h
pawn and the c pawn will be unstoppable
uh there there's no way for the for the
bishop to help out with the promotion of
the pawn if you play something like
bishop to c3 try something very slow h7
is coming then c7 and there's just no no
no no stopping this so instead after
rook to c8 we have g5 by ding uh again
giving magnus away back into the game
now magnus pushes c4 we have g6 f
characters h captures and now king to f8
a very important move uh as you do not
want
your king on e8 when this pawn starts
marching forward and now this would be a
mistake you could play g6 hoping that uh
you know the bishop captures daniel
deliver knight e6 check pick up the
bishop but black can just play king the
g8 and good luck pushing this pawn now
so ding has to figure out something else
he play he finds knight the e6 check
king the g8 and now king the e2 and this
was the i i think uh uh the most
incredible if not uh one of the more
incredible moves in the game because
here uh ding just says you can push your
pawn all you want i'm just gonna put my
king on c1
and
you will not have any squares available
for for your bishop to deliver a check
and there's really nothing else for
magnus to play so we will actually see
this c3 king the d1 and now uh the idea
is c2 is the strongest move here but it
really just gives magnus a slow and
painful death maybe he can survive it
but for example if c2 check king to c1
now there's no square for for the bishop
for you to deliver check uh you can
deliver check here you can't go here and
then here knight covers g5 you can go
here can't go here you can't go here if
you play uh bishop to c3 to try and do
something sneaky then we just capture
and we don't have anything on a dark
square
you can't go here the rook covers this
so it's just a very very sad position
uh to be in so you're gonna have to play
something but it doesn't really work
you're gonna have to play maybe
something like a5 but it's just a
terrible terrible position to play so
instead after king the d1 magnus set i'm
going to play a5 i'm going to allow the
king to create a blockade here on a
light square but this is just completely
lost just give me one second i think
middle wants to come
it's like he smelled that the game is uh
becoming more and more interesting uh so
here magnus played a5 he allowed uh a
king to c2 but uh ponta c2 was really
the only counter play magnus had so king
to c2 was played but now comes rook to
a8 and now how can how can magnus play
this uh you can see that he can never
move the rook away from the back rank
because the knight and pawn uh control
all of these squares so if the rook ever
moves from the back rank rugby it will
be checkmate or rook anywhere on
along the back rank so he can't move the
rook the bishop can't really move
because you have to keep an eye on this
spawn so
magnus is without move so can being uh
try and triangulate maybe magnus into a
completely losing position maybe into a
tsuku swung
let's see how ding plays this we have
rook to b5 bishop to f6 by magnus rook
to b6 now bishop to e5 and now rook back
to b7 so ding played rook b5 rogue b6
rogue back to b7 he repeated the exact
same position only now it's carlson's
move so he successfully triangulated the
position with the rook usually you do it
with the king
and now he wants to see what magnus will
play so here bishop to f6 and now rook
to c7 now uh he uh
keeps uh uh
guarding the the c3 pawn with the rook
and now his plan is actually the
position from the thumbnail so now he's
uh preventing the rookman coming to see
it at any point and now he just wants to
bring the king
into the position and check made the
black king so bishop to e5 and now ding
starts his king march king to d3 bishop
to f6 now king the e4
bishop to e5 there's nothing magnus can
do again all of the weaknesses still
remain if the rook ever moves from the
back rank is just checkmate so king f5
uh and now rook to b8 are trying to
maybe activate the rook a little bit but
it doesn't work king to g5 and now
magnus just repeats rook to a8 no you
cannot go here because you just get
checkmated this is just a terrible
position very very ugly for magnus
so rook to a8 and now comes king to h6
rook to e8 and here dangerous played g7
and he was in this position on 49 that
magnus carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
so really really incredible stuff to
give you an example uh after something
like c2 is played we're just going to
play king the g6 and this is basically
the the the idea from the thumbnail
where you can see that so many
checkmates are are being threatened like
rook and hum come here here and then
chuck made the black king this way or if
something like rook the b8 displayed we
can even play rook to f7 this is now
even stronger rook to f8 is coming so
now we force black to capture here and
after bishop captures on g7 we can just
play rook captures king to h8 and now
knight to g5 this is very important as
we allow black to promote this pawn to a
queen but then knight to f7 is a
smothered mate
so of course black cannot play this he
has to play rook to f8 and guard the f7
square but we still play this knight to
f7 check rook captures rook captures and
again we invite black to promote the
pawn to a queen to deliver rook to f8 to
checkmate so of course black cannot do
this black has to try something else but
after black plays king to g8 or
something like this then we play rook to
f1 we prevent the pawn from queening and
uh well either black now gives up the
pawn or black goes king back to h8 and
then rook to f8 will be checkmate so
this would be the end to this
magnificent uh king march of dings uh
that ended with with uh the move g7 but
it was so beautiful that i i thought you
might guys i thought you guys might
enjoy it if i play it out all the way to
the end
uh so that's the game very glad to see
ding back in action and playing good
chess magnus missed something up there
in the opening probably uh probably the
thing that we've discussed here knight
h3 is unknown move so maybe magnus
thought that that was the position and
knight captures and e4 was still a valid
move but after you know everything just
got in between then it wasn't and uh
well dean just played it very very uh
well not maybe to absolute precision but
for a rapid game uh just incredible
taking down magnus like this uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank brooks uh liz
lizzy and force uh cds for trade team
solo and kojo wushu for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing with the coverage of
this incredible event so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day